the u.s capitol building is in lockdown
right now supporters of president trump
have converged on washington
to try to overturn the election results
from last november
security barricades have apparently been
breached outside the capitol building
police we are told have fired some tear
gas
uh protesters and the doors of the
senate chamber
have been closed and locked it was
inside the senate where they were going
to
ratify that election result from the
vice president mike pence who presides
over the senate
has apparently been escorted to a secure
location
other senators and congressmen and women
are apparently sheltering in their
offices the protesters
are trying to stop congress from
formally approving president-elect joe
biden's victory
back in november's election and in the
last few minutes uh president trump has
tweeted
that they should stay peaceful of course
the president did
address elements of that crowd earlier
at a rally before
they some of them anyway went up the
steps
of the capitol building and the
president apparently went back to the
white house but
has tweeted that any protest should stay
peaceful let's
get the latest let's get you up to speed
from the scene
this guy's washington correspondent greg
milam is there and greg what i want you
to do first of all is is just give us
the sequence
of events both inside the
capitol building and uh what has
happened with those
crowds there how they got there why
they're there
yeah and you can you can see those
crowds still on the steps of the uh the
us capital pretty unprecedented
i've got to say for those who've watched
what goes on in washington over many
years
i think this is this is quite
astonishing what we're seeing inside and
outside of the
the capital but yeah it all started
earlier with many of these people
who were down at a rally down near the
white house
the other end of the national mao donald
trump there giving a
giving a speech again repeating his
claims that the election had been stolen
from him
laying out in an hour-long speech what
he said was the evidence much of which
we've heard before and has been
dismissed by the courts of course but
giving that speech and again encouraging
those
protesters to continue uh with their
protest now
when he finished uh and in fact during
that speech he said he would be with
them on this uh that they they began
this march as was always planned
up to the capitol building the building
you're seeing there
they began that march and by the time
they got here
these first flashes of violence it
appears many of those protesters were
intent on on getting inside the capitol
building
because inside of there was this uh this
joint session of the the house of
representatives and the senate the two
chambers
which was convened to formally certify
the
the result of november's presidential
election and this tension that existed
for the vice president mike pence
and throughout donald trump's speech he
continued to put pressure on mike pence
to do something in that certification
process to overturn the election now
according to the constitution he can't
do that no one expected that mike pence
really would do that but donald trump
continued to pile the pressure on
his vice president and certainly ramped
up the crowd i think
to demand more of the vice president in
this what is a ceremonial role where
that hearing began
even before mike pence has started
speaking he'd released a text of a
letter that he sent to members of
congress
in which he said he wanted people to air
their protests
members of congress to to air their
concerns about electoral fraud
for that to be debated but said that he
didn't constitutionally
have the right to overturn the election
to do anything other than just
accept these votes and move on so at
some point mike pence will announce that
joe biden has been elected
president kamala harris elected vice
president it's a ceremonial moment we've
never taken any notice really of it in
previous years
that will happen at some point but
currently that hearing is
suspended because of a concern about the
safety of those inside
it's reported that some of these
protesters have managed to breach the
the doors of the uh of the the capitol
building
uh the building itself has been locked
down many of the members of congress
inside
told a shelter in place uh concerns
about about tear gas and concerns about
people
get in getting in who are clearly very
angry the president has tweeted that
they should stay peaceful they should
respect
uh law and order they should respect law
enforcement uh who are trying to protect
uh that building it came a little late
because i think these
the anger boiled over long before that
uh that tweet came and you can you can
see the scene
there and we've seen images from inside
of people uh continuing that that
protest
uh and clearly the anger is very real
amongst donald trump's uh supporters
most
of them completely peaceful i've got to
say and we're standing here watching
many of them filtering their way out of
washington but but a hard core
of them uh remaining to make these
points
and as we've seen in some previous
protests in washington in recent months
since november
they have boiled over generally those
those
clashes have been against some of those
counter protesters those from the other
side of the political spectrum here this
one
is largely a clash with uh the capitol
police who protect this building
but also a clash with democracy itself
if you like this is where
a democratic process is going on and
they are many of them trying to storm
that building to put a stop to it